und wir gehen jetzt direkt nach russland
nach moskau wo unser reporter peter
tiede mittlerweile eingetroffen ist
peter beschreibt es so aus das gehört
was paul gesagt hat wie wird das
wahrgenommen überhaupt es gab heute
meldungen unter anderem auch dass die
seite der russischen nachrichtenagentur
tass gehackt wurde und auch das ist ein
zeichen dafür dass ein bisschen die
kontrolle verloren geht in moskau wie
nimmt die öffentlichkeit das war werden
die tatsachen inzwischen dort realisiert
nein wir standen heute vor der
nachrichtenagentur tass und beim tas
gebäude läuft immer um ein laufband mit
der meldung dass nach wie vor nur von
einer spezialoperation die jede der kurs
abstoßen rubel und an der börse wird
einfach nur nüchtern vermeldet ohne
begründung aber das system ist
hochnervös wir haben heute so viele
busse mit maskierten soldaten angehören
der nationalgarde gesehen wie noch nie
ross guardia das ist eigentlich die
präsidentengarde wladimir putin hat die
gründen lassen weil er dem rest nicht
vertraut das ist quasi seine seine gabe
seine aufpasser und die sind hier heute
mit 40 50 bussen durch die stadt
gefahren hinter dem kreml lang mannes
hoch nervös aber die richtige lage kommt
hier nur langsam an wir haben heute
einmal die bilder die peter hell und
paul ronzheimer aus kiew geschickt haben
diese bewegenden bilder vom bahnhof die
haben wir heute spontan einmal auf der
rückseite des kremls vor der linie
bibliothek iaaf angezeigt kira und
moskau angezeigt und wollten wir wissen
ob sie die bilder überhaupt kennen
vielleicht können wir da mal reingucken
juni bis
in diesem jahr ihr studio ist nur ein
beispiel
[Musik]
die ihr stroh ich mir gut wie guttenberg
aber wo ich hinwill jährigen dann
passiert ist total
bibel fliegen vom
4000 gewaltbereiten
auch
zu hause ist auch bibel aufliegen fromm
wie kochen waschen war will man
entschuldigung
es ist weiter
fraglich
peter unglaubliche bilder
also wir haben jetzt die besetzung nicht
gehört aber ganz am anfang hat man eine
frau gehört die
die fürchterlich geschimpft hat auf die
nazis in der ukraine die komplett volle
möhre auf propaganda gepolt war und
ansonsten waren die leute wirklich
entsetzt ich hatte zwei junge frauen
dabei die hatten wirklich tränen in den
augen die haben sich geschämt in grund
und boden
und viele hatten auch einfach angst
entsteht überall steht polizei und die
leute werden auch direkt wenn sich nur
233 leute da an an dieser linie
bibliothek dessen bekannter ort für
demonstrationen werden die sich treffen
werden die abgeführt auch bei uns kamen
dann die polizei und die polizei wollte
uns vertreiben und dann habe ich den
polizisten die bilder gezeigt und dann
hat der polizist geguckt dem kam die
tränen in die augen und der polizist
sagte gut wenn die leute nicht mit dir
reden wollen dass sie bitte einfach in
ruhe aber die anderen darfst du fragen
habe ich noch ein bisschen weiter
gefragt nach der tat da kommen lasse und
dann ist er gegangen weil man hat sich
geschämt man kennt diese bilder hier
nicht und wir waren für viele leute
jetzt die ersten die ihn gezeigt haben
dass er tatsächlich krieg ist und dass
er nicht sondern operation stattfinden
sondern das in kiew die sirenen heulen
und dass die menschen verzweifelt
fliehen frauen und kinder mit ihrem hab
und gut die stadt verlassen wollen und
panik haben und das hat die leute die
meisten hier komplett beschämten das ist
die große gefahr für wladimir putin der
steht hier auch ein bisschen mit dem
rücken zur wand und du hast vorhin
gefragt nach den soldaten bitten das ist
entscheidend weil hier werden die
opferzahlen traditionell nicht genannt
deswegen nennt wladimir putin die
operation auch den krieg auch eine
sonder operation weil im kriegsfall wäre
er gesetzlich verpflichtet die
todeszahlen zu veröffentlichen und
normalerweise werden aus der ukraine die
toten russischen soldaten raus geschafft
und werden fast zum beispiel in taganrog
auf einem auf einen friedhof ich war
selbst mal da da gibt es eine stelle da
werden normalerweise abgetriebene oder
tote föten begraben oder einzelne
körperteile die irgendwo die in
krankenhäusern amputiert werden mussten
da hat man die soldaten heimlich
verscharrt jetzt die krematorien kommt
das alles raus plus die wirtschaftskrise
die sich hier dramatisch an
bedeutet dann wird's eng vladimir putin
mit der es ist unglaublich muss man
sagen die menschen in russland viele
jedenfalls wissen nicht was passiert und
du der bild reporter
zeigt es ihn wäre ich möchte dich noch
ganz kurz fragen das ist eine sache die
bei uns natürlich für angst und
schrecken gesorgt hat wir haben auch
gestern schon darüber gesprochen dass
wladimir putin seine atomraketen in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt hatte
alarmbereitschaft
das bedeutet auf eine eskalationsstufe
von vier stufen allerdings erst die
stufe 2 es gibt noch zwei weitere stufen
das heißt also es ist noch keine ganz
ganz unmittelbare bedrohung trotzdem wir
haben mal geschaut auf die karte wo
stehen denn dieser atomraketen und wie
weit können die überhaupt fliegen und
wenn man dann mal schaut in kaliningrad
sind sie stationiert und die reichweite
ist so weit dass sie tatsächlich und wir
wollen keine panik machen aber es ist
dann doch die realität die können bis
nach deutschland fliegen bis frankfurt
an der oder beispielsweise also ganz in
den östlichen teil der serie ist auf der
karte
480 kilometer reichweite haben diese
atomar bestückte kurzstreckenraketen
also bis kurz vor berlin können sie
fliegen
ja ich war selbst vor einigen jahren
damit man kann man jetzt hinter der
kamera der täter der kamera steht waren
wir vor einigen jahren da und hatten wir
als erste berichtet das ist diese
atomwaffen dort tatsächlich wiedergibt
und nach unseren informationen sind
jedoch aufgerüstet worden und wladimir
putin will ja auch in belarus wieder
atomwaffen stationiert da fand gestern
ein scheinen referendum statt in
weißrussland dass die dass diese
stationierung wieder ermöglichen soll
und damit dann kommen da wirklich welche
hin die auch weiter reichen also wir
sind und wir wären unmittelbar bedroht
und der verteidigungsminister seine
scheidung hat ja heute noch mal auch
noch mal die pacific sorten und anderen
nuklear flotten und truppenteile in
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft versetzt
und es ist halt nicht die einfache
alarmbereitschaft sondern es ist die
stufe vor der gefechtsbereitschaft und
das ist schon wirklich etwas was wir
schon ewig schon ganz lange in europa
nicht mehr hatten überhaupt auf der
ganzen welt
und dass ich gebe es auch mittel und
langstrecken atomar bestückte waffen
gitter es gibt auch immer wieder fragen
denn den geisteszustand der würde mir
putins betreffenden haben wir schon
öfter besprochen aber auch wenn man auf
die bilder von ihm schaut sieht in der
tat sehr aufgedunsen aus dann gibt es
wieder auch gerüchte er sei womöglich
gar nicht mehr in moskau irgendwo in
einem bunker im ural sind das alles nur
gerüchte oder kann da auch was dran sein
was wir wissen inzwischen und zwar
gesichert wissen relativ also sag mal so
weit wie man das gesichert rauskriegt
aus geheimdienstkreisen und von woanders
her wladimir putin im prinzip ständig in
bewegung er ist an unterschiedlichen
orten ist man im kreml da taucht ab und
zu mal auf bilder werden aber dann in
der regel zeitversetzt gesendet wir
kennen das von den videos von den
ansprachen die aufgenommen hat in der in
der vergangenen woche die sind ja
teilweise stunden später oder aber sogar
tage später dann erst veröffentlicht
worden die waren also auf vorrat
produziert wladimir putin ist in der
regel nicht mehr dort wo man ihn dann im
fernsehen sieht da wird schon darauf
geachtet dass niemand sagen kann jetzt
das protein da steht da mal eine rakete
oder eine bombe hoch das nicht es gibt
eine nuklear bunker der ist tatsächlich
im ural da war er wohl auch und
ansonsten wird er ständig rum gebracht
wladimir putin hat diverse willen und
residenzen ist ein sieben stücke die man
kennt es kommt noch andere mit dazu wir
kennen die bilder wie er in sibirien
jagen und angeln war da hat eine
residenz er hat in sotschi ein eine
offizielle residenz er hat eine sogar in
kaliningrad in dieser exklave dem alten
königspaar kann eine oben in karelien
nördlich von sankt petersburg also man
kann ihn im gesamten land ringsherum
bringen und er hat ja auch so was wie
eine air force one auf russisch mit der
rumfliegen kann nur also er ist
permanent in bewegung ist nicht an
festen orten und erst in der regel nie
da wo man ihn grad vermutet
frage ist der druck der aufgebaut wird
auch der wirtschaftliche druck wie groß
wird der sein und was wird er bewirken
wird er ihn zum aufgeben wird der ihn
zum aufgeben stimmen oder wird er im
gegenteil sozusagen als seine letzten
mittel aufbieten in diesem moment kommt
auch die meldung herein dass die schweiz
die eu sanktionen gegen russland über
das beschloss der bundesrat in bern
heute angesichts der anhaltenden
russischen angriffe gegenüber der
ukraine die schweiz das war ja so etwas
wie der letzte hafen schwer in die
kritik geraten auch heute weil dort
natürlich viele oligarchen auch ihr geld
geparkt haben jetzt also auch dieser
sicherer hafen finanziell gesehen
geschlossen was wird das was wir das
bewerten
also es gibt ganz interessantes zeichen
heute hat ja wurde mir ansehe lenski der
ukrainische präsident
putin nano die gleichen und besitzer von
vom fc chelsea herrn abramowitsch
gebieten zu vermitteln das hat einen
ganz konkreten hintergrund abramowitsch
so heißt es selbst in moskau dränge
putin dazu diesen krieg zu beenden
wladimir putin allerdings steht auch
dass nach so weit sieht man dann wie man
das hier erfährt und auch woanders
erfährt aus deutschland zum beispiel von
von sicherheitsdiensten steht relativ
mit dem rücken zur wand er kann keinen
friedensvertrag mit der ukraine
schließen der ihn denn der der schritt
zurück wäre da die mir putin muss
irgendetwas vorweisen momentan hat
nichts vorzuweisen
er hat ein paar großstädten hatte
erobert aber mehr ist es nicht er hat
keine gewalt über die ukraine erlangt
deswegen werden jetzt auch also uns ist
gesagt von und zwar wirklich im
originalton von sicherheitskreisen aus
dem westen die sich auch auf leute hier
im kreml und im umfeld des gremiums
berufen haben wladimir putin könne
ähnliche paul das beschrieben hat und
auch klitschko es beschrieben hat eine
art and schlacht führen wollen alles
reinwerfen was er hat um einen
wirklichen sieg zu erringen koste es was
es wolle weil er kann dich zurück
erkannten dies anders machen das ist das
was wir erwarten und was sich auch
abzeichnet wann ist sind wie alle
russische und tschetschenische kämpfer
nach russland in die ukraine nach
geführt worden die berichte gibt es und
es gibt die gerüchte darüber die relativ
handfest sind dass wladimir putin neue
waffensysteme in die ukraine bringt
selbst welche die ja noch nicht getestet
hat das heißt die verhandlungen die dort
gerade an
region belarus und der ukraine
stattfinden sind reine makulatur und im
besten fall für putin am moment und zeit
zu gewinnen
ja also ein mann der alle verträge die
er bisher unterzeichnet hat zerrissen
hat und auf den müllhaufen der
geschichte geworfen hat dem kann man
schlicht und ergreifend nichts betont
dass der neuen vertrag schließen will
peter tiede live aus moskau wo die
menschen nicht wissen was passierte und
peter thiele der bild reporter hat es
ihnen gezeigt